man kann sich ja heutzutage vor
wundermittelchen kaum
seit ich jeden morgen brunnenwasser mit
einer vierten gurke träge fühle ich mich
viel fitter vieles davon ist zum
verzweifeln aber mein gott es kommt ja
niemand dabei zu schaden meistens leider
gibt es gefährliche ausnahmen darf ich
vorstellen mms medical solution die
wunder mineral lösung der name kommt
nicht von ungefähr das zeug soll alles
mögliche heilt krebs autismus malaria
man kann es ganz einfach und rezeptfrei
im internet bestellen was steckt
dahinter rolle der sonne setzt euch hohe
durch den werdet ihr heute brauchen für
ihre nerven
[Musik]
hallo freunde der sonne ich bin es
wieder mal eure chemikerin des
vertrauens ich werde in den kommentaren
immer wieder nach mms gefragt und ich
habe tatsächlich durch eure kommentare
selbst zum ersten mal davon gehört warum
ich jetzt ein ganzes video darüber
machen muss
das werde täglich sehen die basics
zuerst was ist mms american medical
solution besteht aus zwei teilen erstens
ein salz namens natriumchlorid
natriumchlorid ist übrigens nicht zu
verwechseln mit unseren geliebten
kochsalz natriumchlorid nur mal zum
vergleich natriumchlorid und nathan
chlorid zweitens braucht man eine säure
zum aktivieren aktivieren heißt nachdem
chlorid und säure reagieren und es
entsteht eine verbindung namens
chlordioxid in der chemischen industrie
ist das eine gängige reaktion um
chlordioxid frisch herzustellen aber man
kann claudio xceed auch als bereits
fertige lösung kaufen was in der ms
nutzer szene als cdl abgekürzt wird was
macht man mit chlordioxid chlordioxid
ist ein starkes oxidationsmittel das
heißt es eignet sich hervorragend als
bleichmittel oder als
desinfektionsmittel von meinem video zur
challenge wisst ihr vielleicht das
waschmittel oxidationsmittel enthalten
um verfärbungen und schmutz zu bleichen
sprich zu zerstören doch
oxidationsmittel
meist nicht besonders selektiv das heißt
sie zerstören auch alles mögliche zum
beispiel textilfarben oder fasern
weswegen feinwaschmittel zum beispiel
auch kein bleichmittel enthalten ist
chlordioxid ist auch ein viel
einsetzbares oxidationsmittel als
klassisches bleichmittel kommt es beim
papier gleichen zum einsatz
es kann aber auch bestandteile von
zellen zum beispiel proteine gleichen so
dass man es einsetzen kann um bakterien
und keime zu töten also als
desinfektionsmittel in geringen
konzentrationen benutzt man es zu
trinkwasser desinfektion in höhe
konzentrierten lösungen benutzers zur
desinfektion von laborgeräten oder
oberflächen oder eben nicht als lösung
sondern als gas zur gebäudereinigung von
verschimmelten gebäuden ist und wer
spielt denn das gas kommt dann über hin
wo man sonst nicht hinkommt und in den
usa wird chlordioxid auch zur
desinfektion von hühnchen verwendet
stichwort chlor hühnchen okay soweit so
normal das ungewöhnliche ist dass dieses
zeug nicht nur zum bleichen und
desinfizieren gut sein soll sondern auch
ein medizinischer heiliger gral alles
1996 an mit einem amerikaner namens jim
hampel schauen wir uns das mal genauer
how did we get them humble anhänger der
scientology-sekte war nach eigenen
angaben im dschungel unterwegs mit ein
paar mitreisenden als sie an malaria
erkrankten und er hatte angeblich die
spontane eingebung dass sein
mitgebrachtes wasser desinfektionsmittel
doch bestimmt gegen malaria hilft und
prompt halte er angeblich seine mit
reisen sind und später auch sich selbst
dann gründete er seine eigene siegte in
der er mms und andere medizin kurzerhand
zu heiligen sakramenten erklärte
schuster
jim humble behauptet mit m&ms
zehntausende menschen geheilt zu haben
jim haben will ist nicht der einzige der
auf mms und cd l schwört es gibt dazu
bücher von verschiedenen autor auch in
deutschland darin wird akribisch
beschrieben wie man das bleichmittel
schlucken sollte mal das kennen wir doch
aber nicht nur das man kann sich auch
nur damit einreiben
darin baden oder als rektalen einlauf
benutzen bitte was die taler isle of man
soll sich das ding in den hintern spülen
helfen soll es gegen alles von fußpilz
über krebs ist eben natürlich auch bei
tieren und kindern beweise für eine
derartige wirkung gibt das wohlgemerkt
keine ich bekomme immer wieder zu sehen
dass das wissenschaftlich orientierte
menschen kommen und sagen wo sind die
beweise natürlich beweisen können wir
somit briefe und etwas in
facebook-gruppen tauschen sich ms
anwender aus in der größten
deutschsprachigen facebook gruppe waren
bis vor kurzem 34.000 mitglied letztes
jahr schloss facebook diese größte
gruppe mit verweis auf die gemeinschaft
standard wo drinsteht dass man keine
aktion unterstützen darf bei denen leute
verletzt werden trotzdem gibt es heute
noch mehrere solcher gruppen mit
tausenden mitgliedern okay seid ihr
bereit für ihr schiff die dosis macht
das gift selbstverständlich gilt nur bei
ein stoff industriell zum bleichen
verwendet wird heißt das nicht
automatisch dass eine geringere
konzentration nicht medizinisch genutzt
werden könnte
die dosis macht das gift es gibt sogar
medizinische anwendungen von chlordioxid
zum beispiel zum desinfizieren der
zitzen von kühen nach dem melken damit
sie sich nicht entzünden oder man kann
es auch als desinfizieren das mundwasser
einsetzen
beides sind aber nur oberflächlich
desinfizierende anwendungen man schob
das mit wasser ja nicht und in
geringeren konzentrationen ist es wie
gesagt auch zum desinfizieren von
trinkwasser safe zumindest gibt es da
einen grenzwert den wasserwerke
einhalten müssen und der vor schäden
schützt aber in den büchern und auf den
websites und in den foren wird was ganz
anderes empfohlen nämlich 100 bis 1000
mal höhere dosen und das soll angeblich
kein problem seien hier steht zum
beispiel eine konzentrierte mms
so kann dunkle stoffe bleichen eine
handelsübliche chlordioxid lösung
erreicht diesen effekt jedoch niemals
unser meillerghp redakteur lars hat
diese handelsübliche chlordioxid lösung
ein mal experimentell nachgeprüft dabei
kam raus nicht nur leicht 0,3 prozent
die oxid lösung sehr stark auch
verdünnungen davon so wie sie zur
einnahme empfohlen werden entfernten ein
stück stoff ist keine gleich
wenn ein oxidationsmittel so ein stoff
gleichen kann dann kann das auch
biologisches gewebe zerstören das ist
einfach fakt doch die leute die mit m ms
oder ctl geld verdienen haben sehr
kreative argumente um diesen fakt zu
verschleiern und das ärgerliche ist sind
wirklich verdammt gut darin
wissenschaftlich zu klingen sounds like
science die fiesen tricks der experte
schauen wir doch mal ein paar konkrete
beispiele an wie mms oder cdl experten
bull steht als wissenschaft verkaufen
behauptung chlordioxid ist selektiv eine
wichtige behauptung ist das chlordioxid
zwar bakterien viren angreift aber
menschliches gewebe nicht ihr kennt doch
vielleicht aus dem bio unterricht den
begriff oxidativen stress die beschreibt
wie zellen durch oxidationsmittel
geschädigt werden von antioxidantien
habt ihr bestimmt auch schon gehört die
sind deshalb so gesund weil sie
antioxidans zellen vor oxidation
schützen und obwohl jedem chemiker diese
basic reddoxx eame glasklar ist kommen
die mms oder cdl groß daher und
bombardieren die leute mit chemischen
möchtegern franken wir haben redox
potenziale rausgekramt zahlen genannt
ist hier völlig sinnlos dem körper ein
redox potenzial zuzuordnen das ist
ungefähr so als würde ich der stadt
berlin eine körpergröße von 1 61
zuordnen
nicht so frech da werden grundlegende
chemischen zusammenhänge einfach
den oscar zions bitte schaden
biologischen zellen egal ob die von
bakterien oder von menschen sind hier
sind jetzt typische redox prozess in
einer zelle und all diese stoffe können
von chlordioxid oxidiert werden übrigens
ist auch sauerstoff oxidationsmittel nur
dass unser körper mit entsprechenden in
zügen perfekt umgehen kann klo dioxid
hingegen macht einfach alles kaputt das
einzige was ich hier zeigt dass es noch
stärkere oxidationsmittel gibt als
chlordioxid aber klar die oxid reicht
völlig aus um zellen zu schädigen was
sie hier macht ist eine schein
begründung eine verwirrende ablegt
technik das ist genauso wenn ich jetzt
sage bananen sind gelb deshalb machen
bananen impotent dann kann jeder sehen
dass die argumentation quatsch ist wenn
ich aber sage bei bananen bestimmt das
verhältnis von karotinoiden zu
chlorophyll die intensität der du
mindestens im ultravioletten
elektromagnetischen spektrum und deshalb
machen wir dann ganz eindeutig
impotenten hat man als die chemiker
keine chance mehr durchzublicken
und deswegen ist diese taktik geradezu
genial aber lasst euch nicht verarschen
wir werden auch gleich noch sehr
grafisch sehen dass chlordioxid sehr
wohl menschliches gewebe verletzt also
chlordioxid ist selektiv nein neben
diesen klassischen chemie
ablenkungsmanövern werden noch immer
wieder studien von den experten
hinzugezogen behauptung dass mms ein
wunder heilmittel ist beruht auf
wissenschaftlichen studien manche dieser
studien sind schlicht und einfach keine
wissenschaftlichen um es mal höflich
auszudrücken
dazu kommen wir auch noch gleich andere
studien die wirklich wissenschaftlich
sind werden einfach falsch ausgelegt
diese studie wird zum beispiel sehr
gerne zitiert dr
toyota in japan hat leicht ganz kleine
mengen vorgegeben und zwar das war eine
menge von ganz wenig chlordioxid und hat
zwei mäuse gruppen gehabt in rain
mäusegruppe die wurden also mit
vogelgrippe infiziert die extrem tödlich
ist und von der normalen kontrolle
gruppe dieser vogelgrippe sind 70
prozent gestorben
und von der gruppe wo in der luft ein
ganz kleiner mit chlordioxid sind haben
alle überlebt 100 prozent und das ist
ein fakt ja die luft wurde mit geringen
mengen chlordioxid versetzt um zu testen
ob dieses chlordioxid schon ausreicht um
die viren zu töten und das haben sie
gezeigt es ist eine tolle anwendung von
chlordioxid keine frage also so geringe
mengen in die luft zu bringen dass sie
uns noch nicht schaden aber ausreichend
um viren zu töten super es bringt aber
nichts den mäusen chlordioxid als
medikament zu verabreichen sei es vor
oder nach der infizierung ein
oxidationsmittel wie claudio sie ist wie
gesagt relativ und selektiv und relativ
reaktiv das heißt sobald etwas trifft
was es oxidieren kann reagiert es sich
ab und beide sachen sind danach fünf
jahre das oxidationsmittel sub reagiert
und das andere zeug ist oxidiert fertig
das bedeutet wenn claudia ob sie zuerst
auf ihren trifft dann oxidiertes zuerst
servieren wenn das zuerst auf dem
austritt dann akzeptiert es zuerst die
maus das beste was der was passieren
kann ist dass die konzentration so
gering ist dass der maus nichts ausmacht
aber dieses ding ist kein medikament
es ist und bleibt ein
desinfektionsmittel oder bleichmittel
also wissenschaftliche studien falsch
unter dem deckmantel angeblicher
wissenschaft während die anwender
schlicht und einfach verarscht und sie
leiden darunter
übelkeit erbrechen durchfall aber keine
sorge wenn man erbricht sei das nur ein
zeichen dass es wirkt wie sollen sonst
die toten bakterien den körper verlassen
behauptungen erbrechen ist ein gutes
zeichen für diese idee bakterien kotzen
wird ein weiterer wissenschaftlicher
begriff zweckentfremdet nämlich die
sogenannte herxheimer reaktion das ist
eine reaktion des körpers auf
freigesetzte bakterien bestandteile
allerdings vorwiegend bei ganz
bestimmten bakterien nämlich bei so
genannten spiele hätten die meisten
krankheitserreger gehören wohlgemerkt
nicht zu dieser gruppe außerdem
verursachte herxheimer reaktion
typischerweise ganz andere symptome
nämlich fieber und schüttelfrost ähnlich
wie bei einer grippe nicht erbrechen und
durchfall erbrechen ist hier lediglich
die rede
zu des körpers auf bleichmitteln okay
aber ehrlich gesagt ich würde auch
kotzen den kauf nehmen bin ich dadurch
mein krebs heilen könnte deswegen
schauen wir doch mal ging was mms und
cdl alles helfen soll das wundermittel
wir haben ja schon einige krankheiten
genannt aber schauen wir uns doch mal
die vollständige liste an
[Musik]
da schlägt mein bullshit o meter schon
direkt aus kein medikament dieser welt
kann gegen so viele krankheiten helfen
so etwas gibt es nicht und mal ganz
abgesehen davon dass es für diese
heilkräfte keine wissenschaftlichen
belege gibt soll es sogar gegen
krankheiten helfen die es gar nicht gibt
selbst wenn ihr gesund seid solltet ihr
mms nehmen denn ihr werdet mirakulöse
weise herausfinden dass ihr von
parasiten befallen sein
das ganze funktioniert folgendermaßen
man schluckt mms oder verpasst sich das
als einlauf regelmäßig über einen
längeren zeitraum und irgendwann geht
man dann aufs klo gehen und feststellen
dass da komische sachen auskommen das
ist nämlich so viel zu das zeug schadet
keine menschlichen gewebe
darmschleimhaut die abgesondert wird was
ist auch ganz normal ist wenn der darm
mit bleichmittel misshandelt wird und in
diesen schleimhaut stücken glauben
menschen parasiten zu sehen unsere
kollegen von kontraste zeiten solche
fotos einem internisten der bestätigte
dass die schleimhaut die sich abgelöst
hat mit dem entsprechenden schleim und
auf dem einen bild sind sicherlich auch
blut anteile also das ist ja eine
massive schädigung des darmes schuld an
diesem glauben sind menschen wie carrie
rivera sie steht als expertin für die
idee hinter diesen parasiten als beweis
hat sie unter anderem eine studie von
diesem typ von professor dr
alex wolinski es zwar eigentlich
maschinenbauer hat aber mal die dna von
so einem parasiten gewebestück
analysiert um zu beweisen dass dieses
gewebe kein menschliches gewebe ist
sondern irgendeine
risiken dna tja turned out es ist
menschliche dna so sagen es ihm sogar
seine kollegen zumindest die die sich
damit auskennen
das scheint ihn nicht zu überzeugen
er hat da so seine ganz eigenen fragen
wie gesagt dass die schleimhaut die sich
abgelöst haben der sich nicht schämt
sich irgendwo da hinzustellen und so
einen vortrag zu halten und von ms
experten wie so ein bullshit natürlich
mal wieder als wissenschaft verkauft
spitz formuliert es soll hier sehr
wörtlich nehmen freunde der sonne meer
aus einer meinung ist das nämlich nicht
und zwar eine richtig dumme und
besonders tragisch ist die behandlung
von kindern mit autismus durch
verzweifelte eltern denn natürlich
sollen chlordioxid einläufe auch gegen
autismus helfen klar
leute wie carrie rivera behaupten dass
autismus auch nur durch parasiten
ausgelöst wird und sie redet den eltern
ein dass sie ihren kindern diese heilung
vorenthalten wenn sie nichts gegen diese
parasiten in den körpern ihrer kinder
unternehmen manche eltern beobachten
sogar eine verbesserung und sagen ihre
kinder zeigten weniger autistisches
verhalten im besten fall haben die
kinder einfach etwas dazugelernt und ihr
verhalten geändert im schlimmeren fall
checken die kinder dass bestimmtes
verhalten mit 1 läufen bestraft wird und
versuchen dieses verhalten zu
unterdrücken also nochmal mms hat keine
wissenschaftlich nachgewiesenen
heilwirkungen aber dafür gut
nachgewiesene schädliche nebenwirkungen
die frage die bleibt ist warum ist das
internet voll mit positiven
erfahrungsberichten pass auf der witz
ist es geht gar nicht so viel besser die
foren sind voll von menschen denen es
von nms wie zu erwarten
total schrecklich geht doch daraufhin
wären sie nur angefeuert es weiter
zunehmen kein wunder denn genau so
schreiben es ja auch die experten
wir haben beobachtet dass einige
menschen eine extreme abneigung gegen ms
1 entwickelt während sie die behandlung
durchführen
manchmal ist das so schlimm dass die
dosis einfach nicht
mehr einnehmen können ich glaube dass es
dafür eine erklärung gibt möglicherweise
erzeugen die krankheitserreger die
aversion gegenüber mms einst als schutz
mechanismus um die person davon
abzubringen weiterhin das zu tun was sie
zerstören könnte wenn das auf sie
zutrifft dann sollten sie wirklich alles
versuchen um die aversion gegen ms zu
überwinden es ist absolut wichtig dass
sie nicht ganz aufhören
nochmal es handelt sich hier um ein
oxidieren das bleichmittel die lösung
die lars hier benutzt hat ist die
gleiche die autistischen kindern als
einlauf verpasst wird
mit dieser konzentration konnte lars
einwandfreie batik shirts fertigen ich
habe natürlich auch eins bekommen wo mit
etwas höherer konzentration und einer
schablone kann man richtig kohle drucke
selbst machen und diese druck
konzentration ist immer noch deutlich
weniger als das was manche freiwillig
selbst schlucken was wir jetzt außer t
shirts gleichen teilt dieses video
ich werde auch an dem tag wo dieses
video online geht versuchen was auf
twitter zu starten
denn die vernunft muss ich einfach
stärker ausbreiten als irgendeinem
pseudowissenschaftliche bullshit der
menschen dazu verleitet sich selbst und
ihre kinder zu verletzen und wenn ihr
wütend sein glaubt mir das bin ich auch
dann macht ihrem ärger gerne luft in den
kommentaren aber seit so gut und sei
dabei keine arroganten arschlöcher und
beschimpft mms anwender als dumm oder
ähnliches diese menschen sind opfer und
sie haben ein recht auf aufklärung ohne
angegriffen zu werden in opfern kann ich
das nicht übel nehmen ich habe ja selbst
gesehen wie diese experten teilweise mit
doktorat professor titel wird diesen
unglaublich clever gemacht und pseudo
wissenschaftlichen texten und büchern
und fucking redux potenzial daherkommen
ich verstehe überhaupt nicht wieso so
etwas überhaupt erlaubt ist alles was
ich machen kann ist zur aufklärung
beizutragen deswegen danke wirklich
danke das ihr bis hierhin geschaut hat
und als belohnung gibt es in der end
karte etwas besonderes freunde der sonne
hier ist das meine team
wir zwei sind ja schon von anfang an mit
dabei ist unsere grafikerin und auch
sonst hält mir in vielen dingen den
rücken frei und seit januar ist das bei
uns im team maier hat ihn aus dem labor
adcloud so war's also ich bin büro
gehabt bis vor kurzem noch im labor
gestanden neurowissenschaft und
schlafforschung jetzt habe ich noch
cooleren job gefunden nämlich beim
einzuarbeiten
irgendwie sagt ich bin auf jeden fall
super dankbar dass mit lars jetzt ein
zweiter wissenschaftler mit im team ist
das heißt wir haben doppelte recherche
power und doppelte neubauer und ich
hoffe ihr spürt und merkt dass dann auch
bei den videos ich bin auch in den
kommentaren klammer zu finden also ich
helfen mit fragen zu beantworten genau
wenn ihr irgendwo in lassen den
kommentaren findet das ist dieser las
und wisst ihr was ich schon länger nicht
mehr hatten
wer von euch da draußen weiß erhält die
beiden sich eigentlich kennen ist noch
mal so viel
auf dem land gibt es den hinweis dann
müssen wir das heute am abholtag in die
kommentarspalte schreiben und wenn dann
bekommt hier